SEE YOU TOMORROW, EVERYBODY.
HAVE A GOOD NIGHT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON."
AN UPDATE ON THE WORLD’S DULLEST
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
IF SOMETHING SIGNIFICANT
HAPPENS, WILL BRING IT TO YOU
RIGHT AWAY.
THE QUESTION IS WHY HAS THIS
BEEN SO BORING?
WELL, BECAUSE IT DOESN’T MEAN
ANYTHING TO IT RATHER THAN A
DEBATE OVER THINGS THAT MATTER,
YOU ARE WATCHING PURPORTED ADULT
YELL AT EACH OTHER WHETHER A
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT’S
NE’ER-DO-WELL MIDDLE-AGE SON
SHOULD INTERRUPT HIS EARLY
RETIREMENT IN L.A. AND COME TALK
TO THEM.
HONESTLY?
WHO CARES.
WHATEVER.
FOR ONCE, WE DO HAVE A
SEMIINTERESTING DEVELOPMENT
TONIGHT.
APPARENTLY SOME DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS ARE CONSIDERING CASTING
VOTES TO ACQUIT DONALD TRUMP.
NEW REPORTS SUGGEST THAT
SENATORS JOE MANCHIN OF
WEST VIRGINIA, KYRSTEN SINEMA OF
ARIZONA, AND DOUG JONES OF
ALABAMA ARE UNDECIDED ON THE
PRESIDENT’S GUILT.
THAT’S A STORY.
UNDECIDED?
HOW COULD THEY BE UNDECIDED
ABOUT THIS?
IT’S NOT LIKE IT’S A TOTALLY
FRAUDULENT EXERCISE IN PARTISAN
POLITICS.
NO, NOT AT ALL.
IF YOU’VE BEEN WATCHING THEY
KNOW THAT THIS IS NOTHING LESS
THAN AND WE WANT TO BE TOTALLY
CLEAR ABOUT THIS, AND NATIONAL
SECURITY CRISIS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO OUR FREE
AND FAIR ELECTIONS AND OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS AN ONGOING
THREAT TO OUR ONGOING SECURITY.
>> THE PRESIDENT BETRAYED OUR
SECURITY AND UNDERMINED THE
SECURITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
>> UNDERMINED ARE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> SO HE COULD KEEP POWER.
>> HE HARMED AMERICA’S NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WE MUST ACT WITHOUT DELAY.
>> DID YOU HEAR THAT?
ARE YOU LISTENING CAREFULLY?
THE PRESIDENT UNDER MY NATIONAL
SECURITY AND HE DID IT ON
PURPOSE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IS?
IT’S TREASON, AS THEY’LL TELL
YOU ON
WHO REFUSED TO STOP OR PUNISH OR
CONVINCE DELMA CONVICT THEM.
ARE THEY GUILTY OF TREASON TOO?
OF COURSE THEY ARE, THEY ARE
COLLABORATORS.
NOT LONG UNTIL WE SEE THE
IMPEACHMENT TRIALS OF JOE
MANCHIN, KYRSTEN SINEMA, OR DOUG
JONES.
IT WAS NOT AMERICA BETRAYED, IT
WAS PERHAPS FAR MORE
IMPORTANTLY, THE NOBLE PEOPLE OF
UKRAINE, THE CRANIUMS, OUR MOST
IMPORTANT ALLIES IN THE GLOBAL
WAR AGAINST PUTINISM.
LISTEN TO ADAM SCHIFF EXPLAIN.
>> THE IMPORTANCE OF UKRAINE’S U
OUR NATIONAL SECURITY, MAKES THE
SUPPORT ALL MORE DESERVING.
IT WOULD’VE WEAKENED OUR ALLIES
AND EXPOSED U.S. TROOPS
STATIONED IN EUROPE TO GREATER
DANGER.
WE ONLY DETER RUSSIA BY
CONSISTENTLY DEMONSTRATING
SUPPORT FOR OUR FRIENDS.
FRIENDS LIKE UKRAINE.
THAT IS WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT TO
OUR SECURITY THAT WE STAND WITH
UKRAINE.
COUNTRIES LIKE UKRAINE FIGHTING
OUR FIGHT AGAINST
AUTHORITARIANISM.
GOD HELP US IF IT’S NOT OUR
FIGHT, STILL.
>> Tucker: GOD HELP US,
IMPLORES AMERICA AS WARRIOR
PRIEST ADAM SCHIFF.
STAND WITH UKRAINE, FOR THE LOVE
OF GOD, MAN!
STAND WITH UKRAINE!
AS GENERATIONS ON THE DEATHBEDS
HAVE SAID TO THEIR OLDER SONS,
BOY, STAND WITH UKRAINE!
BECAUSE EVEN NOW, IN THIS MODERN
AGE THAT WE DARE TO CALL
CIVILIZED, THERE ARE DARK FORCES
WORKING UNSEEN IN THE SHADOWS
EVEN NOW.
FORCES IF LEFT TO THEIR OWN
DIABOLICAL DEVICES MIGHT BRIEFLY
DELAY THE TRANSFER OF
SOPHISTICATED WEAPONS TECHNOLOGY
THAT HAVE IGNITED PEOPLE OF THAT
HOLY NATION UKRAINE.
THAT, AS CORY BOOKER ONCE
EXPLAINED WITH A TOTALLY
STRAIGHT FACE, WOULD BE TREASON.
>> WE ARE REALIZING THAT THE
PRESIDENT WITHHOLDING THAT AID
NOT FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
PURPOSES, IN FACT VIOLATING
NATIONAL SECURITY INTERESTS, TO
PURSUE HIS OWN PERSONAL BENEFIT.
THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND IN MY
OPINION THAT IS TREASONOUS.
>> Tucker: TREASONOUS.
THE QUESTION AT THIS POINT IS
WHAT YOU DO WITH TREASON.
DO YOU LOOK AWAY AND DON’T
PRETEND YOU SEE IT?
DO YOU LET IT PASS WITH THE
ACQUITTAL, NOT LIKE EVERY DECENT
RED-BLOODED AMERICAN, YOU DON’T
LOVE UKRAINE WITH A SELFLESS
LOVE A PARENT FOR A CHILD,
UNLESS YOU ARE THE KIND OF SOLD
THAT MONSTER WHO PUT THE
INTEREST OF YOUR NATION ABOVE
THOSE OF UKRAINE.
DID YOU KNOW THAT CHICAGO,
ILLINOIS, IS THE SISTER CITY OF
KIEV.
NOT A COUSIN, A SISTER CITY!
SPIRITUALLY NEAR, EFFECTIVELY
THE 51ST STATE.
WHEN UKRAINE SNEEZES, WE AS A
NATION SAY GOD GOD BLESS YOU.
YOU ARE ONE OF US, AS YOU’VE
BEEN FOR CENTURIES UPON
CENTURIES.
ADAM SCHIFF JOINED TOGETHER, LET